alors première séquence christian
lacroix ne dit rien par contre il a
déclaré dans un journal
ma femme et mon conseiller ont tout fait
pour moi alors ce soir on a réuni
beaucoup plus que ta femme et ton
conseillère n'a réussi ni toute la
maison lacroix
je voudrais que tout le monde là après
l'autre me dise ce qu'il a apporté à la
maison lacroix jean jacques picart le
conseiller on commence par toi
je cherche que j'apportais à la
recherche que tu as tenté avec des sons
les coins où je suis sincère et je dis
tout acheteur la wii alors si ça serge
et que j'ai tout va porter et celui-ci
je suis modèles gt que j'ai rien apporté
parce que il avait déjà tout donc c'est
une question un peu
non je crois qu'on a rien le succès
médiatique de la croix tu n'es pas un
peu pour quelque chose
c'est une technique mais j'ai travaillé
pour beaucoup de stylistes ils n'étaient
pas tous capables de décrocher autant de
pages autant d' espaces dans les médias
que lacroix donc je crois qu un peu
technique s'il ya rien à donner
ça sert pas à grand chose un peu de
technique beaucoup de talent beaucoup de
charme ça ça donne beaucoup de résultats
non je crois qu'on n'a rien apporté il
avait tout en lui on a peut-être juste
aider à exprimer
très bien paulo droit vous êtes le
président de la maison lacroix le pdg
vous représentez d'un arnaud dans la
maison on vous voit rarement à la
télévision par mon les journaux je
serais content que vous soyez là ce soir
qu'est ce que vous avez apporté à la
maison lacroix ou combien
ça c'est le prof de bernard arnault
d'avoir participé avec la vie nancy
ragage un apport financier important et
nécessaire pour lance yves une maison de
couture au plan international quant à
quentin moi mon rôle consiste à faire en
sorte que christian soit euros avec mon
actionnaire soit on essaie de satisfaire
les uns et les autres c'est difficile ah
non ça se passe très bien parce que nous
avons sommes tous genres christian et
tous les ans dans cette maison te manque
toujours ce même longueur d'onde et par
conséquent où tout est pas si simple ici
dans tous les sens très bien des choses
ce portrait merveilleusement bien
françoise ce qui est su apporter à
christian lacroix quartier moi je suis
la face cachée de la maison
accroissement c'est la face camarguaise
la croix sur les vacances en fait ouais
ouais vient de chez moi des compressions
bien pensants et puis s'en vont ils sont
contents en fait je suis gentil
organisateur de leurs vacances aux îles
sont contentés vacances en août
je pense qu'ils reviennent moi je le
connaisse ou une autre phase je vous
dirai pas laquelle sera non pas là après
oui alors elizabeth garouste et mattia
bonetti à part la décoration de la
maison lacroix rue du faubourg
saint-honoré
qu'est ce que vous avez apporté à
christian lacroix
tout le dérange pas mais avec
en plastique de
sam
qui s'est fait un peu sans parler comme
ça très est effectivement né comme
disait paul aux draps sur la même
longueur d'onde je crois maintien mais
moi je crains que nous
construit et l'aspect ce décret autour
d'un bijou les festayres mais très
gracieux jessica qui a fait le sait vous
apprêtez mois avant vous aussi christian
poncet les craintes
tu n'as pas le droit de parler toi là
tout de suite tu n'as pas de micro leur
mari senna que le comment on dit
l'égérie le mannequin vedette mais il
peut pas lui même admis c'est exprès
qui le portent un peu c'est je crois que
je suis là quand il a besoin
ces soirées aussi puisque tu vas bientôt
se marier avec hubert boukobza qui est
le patron des endroits gilbert est au
courant ils viennent m'en parlé il m'a
dit que ça pouvait l'annoncé voilà pour
tout le monde
alors maintenant on va voir un sujet qui
a été fait par notre ami franck maubert
où on voit les gens qui travaillent chez
lacroix 73 faubourg saint-honoré qui
parle du patron lancions qu'envoyer le
sujet tu n'as rien à dire tu n'as pas de
micro non plus alors valence ou chez
métro filles marie cesnek mannequin
christian christian christian christian
lacroix christian christian nos
questions à christian christian
christian questions sur la croix annick
joyon directrice du studio je vois pas
de défauts majeurs
[Musique]
diane duke mannequin christ sur la croix
j'adore mais la très très grand défaut
ce qui l'a beaucoup trop de talent ce
mardi matignon féminin monsieur lacroix
quand il fait il fait ses croquis locaux
qui est déjà terminée
[Musique]
jeanine ouvre à le première d'atelier
flou ce côté un peu un peu pas pas très
haute couture finalement un peu un peu
un peu au-delà d'août
va paître gars vous donc je travaille
avec matière on a travaillé au décor
dont on travaille un peu par image et
beaucoup par le monde des vocations
mattia bonetti on joue beaucoup sur des
contrastes entre eux par exemple des
matériaux assez brut mais qui doivent
êtres qui sont réinterprétés d'une façon
assez luxueuse françoise in style
lacroix compagne complice officiel de
monsieur lacroix
c'est un timide 1 kg est un gay triste
je m'appelle ben pourriez tout c'est une
personne qui est très chaude et qui a le
contact facile
terry ray ban
lors du pavillon taché de presse de
christian lacroix
je ne suis pas de camargue mais nous
sommes du même signe j aurais tu as
thierry sharp un artiste peintre il aime
le rose
on a fait du bleu il aime le jaune on a
fait du verre on a évité le rouge mais
on a fait son bureau
[Musique]
et
sur l'autre un président de cette
société bien souvent je l' ai vu dans
des
réunion avoir un rire d'une telle
intensité d'une telle force que toute la
société se sent transporté question du
bois du pastis ouais tu me vois du
pastis pourtant de champagne revient
fort la main de vodka pastis nom
champagne c'est fini c'est fini pour moi
en tout cas c'est à dire que tu as
encore plus en avance que les autres les
gens sont chante ça je ne sais pas pour
faire la grève puisque le gras on a
quelque chose en commun c'est que toi tu
habitais arles moi j'habitais à avignon
j'ai fait mes études à montpellier
enfin je passais ma vie un canard à la
shoah ce qu'aia et puis ensuite
alimenter tous les deux appareils
aujourd'hui tu me parle un peu de cette
époque c'est-à-dire l'époque où le
succès des études d'histoire de l'art à
montpellier et où tu allais la shoah sky
h et jean lafon comment c'est fait tu
sécher les cours
si je suis franc montpellier pour moi
c'était pas j'ai pas accroché vraiment à
montpellier puis j'avais choisi
montpellier parce que mes amis de 15
était est et à montpellier j'aurais
mieux fait de choisir ex mais c'est vrai
que mais la proximité de la camargue
avec cette chose
magic qui a été la source kayak entendus
sur un sky a je crois qu'on parle peu en
initier ouais quand on était des
francs-maçons je sais pas quoi mais
c'est vrai que c'est une c'est un
endroit un lieu qui a maté quelques
années aujourd'hui la télé 20 ans il ya
un an
quitte en pleine camargue
jean laffon puisqu'on peut redire sa
phrase à la came as tu un manadier
devenir propriétaires de chevaux et de
taureaux à des plus importants et il
s'est passé quelque chose de magique là
c'était comme une brute
gauloise qu'un feu au milieu à trouver
le poids pour que la fumée - matin je me
suis réveillé mais ils étaient tous
partis m'avait laissé dehors mais elle
est chaud à la suivre et il fallait
d'abord trouver la route
j'ai couru deux voitures qui se sont
complètement alizés au départ le matin
parce que l'homme salle dans le sable et
ben ça ouvert en 67 68
c'était un endroit où on avait les
musiques selon votre new york en
priorité qui a vécu ici en paix
maintenant qu'il est là et qu'elle va
chercher cette compte et ça fait un peu
anciens combattants et un peu
certains pseudo general ayant tué a
conquis paris donc c'est très à la mode
tout ça tu vas tu as quand même où le
fallait la mode c'est pas le but que je
préfère être un labo et encore moins
l'animent society a quand même fait
fortune à paris
c'est vrai pour faire attention à sa
vasque qui dit être à la botte de di
être vie médian des bonnets à quelque
part et puis la kaaba c'est une chose à
garder précieusement comme un bijou et
faire très attention à pas le galvauder
mais c'est vrai que c'était un lieu
comme ça et c'est vrai que d'en parler
ça fait un peu anciens combattants mais
à l'époque il y avait non seulement les
stones etc
mais charles trenet ce qui est des bleus
est évident pour la faune arrivé c'était
les trompettes d'aïda de verdi et on
restait va jusque 5h 6h 7h du matin et
emporter
se laver aux saintes maries de la mer
dans la baie
et bon voilà et quand tu as quand tu as
quitté tout ça c'est parce que tu savais
que j'avais un destin je sentais au fond
de toi même que tu pouvais pas rester là
qu'il fallait que tu montes atari
prévoit y avait des choses importantes à
faire je crois que que sans présomption
c'était un peu comme un voyage
initiatique qui avait à faire on y avait
des patrons 17e il devait passer par
rome
ben on va voir je dessine et
destinée du théâtre des costumes de
théâtre ou de la mode à montpellier où
avec toi reloue avignon c'était
envisageable qu'un et puis il y avait
c'est une chose qui me
tenait à coeur et je suis arrivé ici en
73 un petit peu plus tard que moi
j'avais combien d'argent en poche quand
tu arrives et 500 francs voir quand on
dit finalement bernard arnault investi
beaucoup d'argent sur christian lacroix
mais christian lacroix a signé sur tout
ça veut dire que tu as signé sur la
haute couture se prête à porter sur les
parfums sur les lunettes sur le sac à
main est ce que tu vas pas un peu
l'impression d'avoir vendu son âme au
diable finalement non vous êtes pris
finalement dans un système qui risque de
dépasser un jour peut-être bon je ne
suis pas devin j'en sais rien mais en
tout cas bernard arnault est quelqu'un
qui m'a parlé au sens où je me suis
senti un peu de la même race et où c'est
quelqu'un
de la même génération que moi et puis
bon peut-être qu'un jour il faut signer
ce genre de pacte avec en tout cas je
les fais en tout
sachant qu'en sachant que je pouvais
garder ma liberté de dire qu'il est
d'accord nous sommes d'accord lui et moi
pour dire que
la qualité c'est pas signé des centaines
de licences sait jamais c'est clair
entre gauche sectaire entre très bien et
on va garder ça attaque
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou